hi my name is Mike burger I'm here
Memorial sloan-kettering cancer center
in new york city i'll be talking today
about applications of next-generation
sequencing to discover biomarkers and
drug response in cancer so as many of
you most of you probably know cancers
can be subdivided into two categories
defined by the specific genetic
alterations harbored in these tumors so
from the last 10 20 years of genomic
research in lung cancer we now know that
lung cancer can be subdivided into K
rescue confirm cancer the ghia from lung
cancer tumors defined by fusions and
alch Neerav from other genes and that
some of these mutations can be targeted
vitamin a novel therapeutic sunni novel
targeted therapies like a lot and
benefited for egfr move on cancer the
same is true for melanoma we're over
about fifty percent of melanomas contain
mutations in the gene be rap and that
these be wrapping melanomas can be
targeted by BF inhibitors like from
laughing into graphing it and one
important point here is that the
mutations that define these tumors that
are most commonly associated with
particular tumor types are often found
to occur at smaller frequencies in other
tumor types like b-raf mutations in lung
cancer we now know from profiling from
for driver mutations and aqua genes in
lung cancer that the raft mutations
occurring about one or two percent and
these be rapidly and lung tumors can be
targeted by the melanoma drugs shown
here in a case report from last summer
from them raffinate i can say from the
experience here at sloan-kettering just
about every european lung cancer patient
who's received and europe inhibitor has
derived some form of clinical benefit
but this now means that the proper
administration of these target therapies
requires molecular diagnostics and with
the genomic diversity and complexity of
cancer requires comprehend
profiling of many genes and many
different tumor types now and I
molecular diagnostics lab here the
workflow can be very complicated so a
lung cancer because of the number of
mutations for which and oncologists may
want to know the status a lung cancer
would undergo many different tests both
for in dale's in particular exons of
egfr and her to buy fragment analysis
other point mutations in egfr through C
a and B wrap k rats there is Sequenom
genotyping sa other point mutations are
interrogated by Sanger sequencing al
confusions and meta amplifications are
crewed by fish testing and ross fusions
by rt-pcr some of this testing is
performed concurrently some sequentially
depending on the mutant and wild-type
status of other genes but with all these
different tests it's actually a very
inefficient workflow and inefficient use
of tissue as the amount of tissue
obtained through biopsies and clinical
surgeries is getting smaller and more
precise so next generation sequencing
offers many advantages over more
traditional single gene diagnostic tests
with next-generation sequencing we can
sequence many genes at once this means
that the testing can be formed using a
single test rather than all of these
lower can put more traditional testing
to more efficient workflow and more
efficient use of tissue and insert
sequencing many genes you can actually
serve a greater fraction of the genome
than even a collection of all all
existing tests this can provide but with
massive perilously consumed you can
sequence entire exons so your analysis
isn't limited to pre specified hot spots
within oncogenes and this makes it
particularly suitable for sequencing and
analyzing tumor suppressor genes where
you can have inactivating mutations
throughout the entire lengths of these
genes with modern approaches you can
rapidly add new biomarkers that emerge
from large-scale sequencing efforts like
the Cancer Genome Atlas International
Cancer Genome consortium and detect
additional types of genomic alterations
as I'll describe we're not just limited
to
mutations but also can examine copy
number alterations and structural
rearrangements which are particularly
climbing like trans occasions which are
particularly common in cancer and may
have clinical at therapeutic
significance and we can do all of this
profile in with greater sensitivity for
low frequency events it may only be
present in a small fraction of tumor
cells due to the higher sensitivity of
the next-generation sequencing
approaches so assuming that most people
in his talk attending this talk of
familiar with next-generation and
massively parallel sequencing for those
of you who may not be as intimately
familiar with it just in a nutshell the
way it works well there are many
different platforms different flavors of
next generation sequencing Ion Torrent
pacific biosciences hung own approaches
since the data that i'll be describing
comes from alumina just 30 second
overview of probably women of platform
works this is a picture of the alumina
hi-c at the core of this instrument is a
flow cell shown here and this is where
you load your DNA sample the rest of the
instrument is a lot of optics and
detectors and fluidics but you'll owe
your DNA sample onto this flow cell the
individual DNA molecules can be
immobilized on the surface of this flow
cell and then imaged at high resolution
after a series of single basin
corporation reactions so with each base
you incorporate one of four different
fluorescently labeled nucleotides you
can take an image of literally billions
of these of these clusters on a single
flow cell and then through a series of
incorporations and images you can you
can read out base by base and accumulate
these strings of nucleotides in the
sequence reads corresponding to each
physical cluster and the flow cell and
these are our sequence reads that we can
then map to the entire reference in the
genome in this example each row
represents a different sequence read
from a different molecule and you can go
position by position through the genome
and look for sites where some of the
reeds differ from the reference sequence
so on the bottom here you can see
reference human genome sequence suggests
with the site leah see but about half of
the reeds contained t indicating that
there's heterogeneity at that site in
the genome for this particular sample
all of these reeds came from one sample
but their independent DNA molecules from
synergy another bit of terminology when
we talk about sequence coverage we're
talking about the number of times any
single position in the gene with
sequence the number of distinct in with
the genome sequence the number of
distinct molecules spanning each
particular site the genome so in this
drawing this is a sequence coverage of
45 x indicating that this site was
sequencing 45 different leads from 45
different molecules and the reason for
this is to be sensitive to low-frequency
mutations it may only be present in
small fraction of molecules and also to
account for potential errors in
sequencing which tends to be so areas in
sequencing requiring redundancy within
the analysis to ensure that as
particular variant that we're seeing is
due to a real underlying sequence
variant and not sequencing noise another
advantage of next-generation sequencing
is that we can distinguish between
mutations and cysts and in trans which
wasn't possible by more traditional
Sanger sequencing approaches you can see
here two adjacent mutations on the left
sample on the Left occur insists a
dinucleotide substitution where is on
the right occurring trans affecting both
alleles which is particularly important
for tumor suppressor genes where you
could have viola with inactivation in in
in cancer or in aqua genes where you
have hot spots where the mutations may
occur in different subclones with an
intern there do your tumor heterogeneity
so when applying is these technologies
to study tumors we encounter many
challenges so some of them are technical
challenges as I alluded to before we're
often confronted with small amounts of
tissue due to small biopsies other
non-invasive procedures so with limited
amounts of tissue
methods need to be adaptable to small
amounts of DNA and the DNA itself could
be degraded or poor quality depending on
the quality of the tissue which is often
a problem for formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue which is the
most common way of storing these
reception specimens other challenges are
due to just the inherent genetic need
genetics of cancer where you can find
sorry you can i'm painting floyd ii mean
too many different copies of a
particular chromosome rather than just
the two copies you'd expect in a diploid
genome tumors can be better at very
heterogeneous where you can have
different sub phones within the tumor or
adjacent normal cell admixture within
the tumor so that a mutation that you're
searching for may only be present in one
out of five copies of a gene in only you
know twenty percent of cells in your
sample because of tumor heterogeneity
and stromal admixture and in cancer were
confronted with the additional challenge
of distinguishing somatic mutations from
inherited variants and to do this we
frequent in sequence two different
samples from a cancer patient one DNA
isolated from the tumor and the other
from match normal tissue to distinguish
between those mutations that were
somatically acquired during the
progression of the tumor versus those
that were inherited but in the face of
these challenges there are many
opportunities which is why so much work
has gone on to adapting these
technologies to study cancer and he's
partially because of the different types
of alterations that can be interrogated
from next gen sequencing it's not just
specific sequencing mutations but other
changes to the DNA including copy number
alterations loss of heterozygosity and
structural rearrangements like
translocations by sequencing see DNA
derived from mrna we can also find a
brantley expressed genes novel gene
fusions alternative splicing novel
splice variants from real specific
expression and other techniques like
chip seek and methyl seek and DNA seek
allowance to monitor the epigenetic
state of tumors but why study why
sequence tumors in the first place
I mentioned some some examples in the
beginning where it's helped us better
understand the biology of tumor that's
probably the first reason from a
discovery science standpoint why we
might be interested in sequence of
tumors it allows us to better understand
cancer biology to design better
therapies and better interventions and
this is through comprehensive analysis
of tumor samples to identify the genes
in the pathways that are significantly
mutated across lots of tumors that may
be important to cancer progression this
provides the rationale for large
consortium projects like the Cancer
Genome Atlas and and the International
Cancer Genome consortium this also
allows us to discover targetable
alterations in common and rare tumor
types and particularly these rare tumor
types may not be part of these large
international and national efforts but
also by taking clinically annotated
tumor samples or samples obtained from
patients who enrolled in a clinical
trial we can discover clinically useful
biomarkers these can be biomarkers that
predict outcomes to novel targeted
therapies or the response or resistance
to targeted therapies or by sequencing
multiple samples from the same patient
either obtained from different
metastasis or longitudinally over time
we can understand a monitor tumor
progression on the acquisition of drug
resistance and finally by sequencing
patient samples as patients are
receiving their care it can lead to
improved clinical diagnostics and better
therapeutic decisions for those
particular patients and so first that
probably the simplest approach for my
from a lab process standpoint although
not necessarily from a computational
analysis standpoint is to sequence the
entire cancer genome so when we sequence
whole cancer genomes we're usually
sequencing two samples from a patient as
i mentioned DNA from the tumor DNA from
the match normal and which is can be
blood it can be adjacent frozen tissue
that can be really any other cell from
the individual that contained a diploid
unaltered genome and we will take DNA
from both samples create sequence
libraries sequencing assignments
Dainius Lee to thirty to sixty fold
coverage and then look for alterations
like the one shown here that are present
in the tumor but absolutely the normal
we didn't throw these to be the somatic
mutations in his tumor sequence the
beads is paired ends from the ends of
fragments of DNA and by sequencing
paired reads we can then identify
structural rearrangements like
translocations where we have several
fragments where the first read maps to
one chromosome and the other read maps
to either a different chromosome or the
same chromosome and an unexpected
position or orientation this is further
shown here in a figure from a review
waiting by former colleagues from the
Broad Institute where they show the
different classes of alterations in
cartoon form in this cartoon each
rectangle represents a fragment of DNA
for orange and in blue boxes represent
the sequence reads sequencing from the
ends and wherever you have a read you
can identify potential point mutations
insertions deletions through gaps in the
alignment with respect to the reference
in the genome and copy number
alterations through a depletion or
enrichment of reads mapping to a given
site we can refer deletions or
amplifications of those genes
translocations can be identified from
pairs of reeds and mapped to different
chromosomes and even non-human sequence
from viruses or bacteria can be
identified that might suggest a
pathogenic basis for that tumor now when
all of these types of alterations it's
almost impossible to capture all the
information you get in a single diagram
to to attempt to do this a lot of the
people in the cancer genomics field have
you have generated talks like this
circus box where concentric rings depict
different classes of alterations
including linking point mutations coding
mutations copy number alterations in the
middle of structural rearrangements
involving individual chromosomes or
spanning multiple chromosomes and it
used to be probably three or four years
ago that just the feet of sequencing a
genome and analyzing all these
alterations was an accomplishment in it
health and worthy of a nature paper even
time senses the technology is improved
and as analysis methods have matured the
projects have changed so rather than
looking at a single genome we can
sequence many genomes for many tumors of
a given tumor type to begin to look for
patterns and understand the significant
alterations important to the biology of
those particular of that particular
tumor type this is an example of one
study that I led the Broad Institute
would Levi Garraway before moving to
sloan-kettering where we sequenced the
entire genomes of 25 metastatic melanoma
patients and looked at similarities and
differences among these tumors this
analysis is going on elsewhere
Washington University genome Institute
is one of the largest contributors
contributors to the global genome
sequencing effort in cancer this is data
from their website from a few months ago
showing the status of a number of
different tumor types where they
sequenced and analyzed hundreds of
individual cases but really this is only
the beginning through the large-scale
collaborative efforts of the ICGC
consortium and the Cancer Genome Atlas
within the next few years we can expect
tens of thousands of whole genomes of
cancer samples deposit in public
databases that will enable the data
mining and discovery of hopefully all of
the relevant to come for current
alterations in these common tumor types
but as great as this is for discovery
it's not obvious that this approach is
optimal for clinical applications or
even some translational research
applications and the reason I say that
is because whole genome sequencing I'll
be a much cheaper than it was a few
years ago still relatively expensive
than the lute ly and for example at
sloan-kettering we have of almost 100
surgeries performed every day so the
idea of bringing this into the clinical
setting for especially whole genome
sequencing is just not practical right
now the whole genome methods typically
require abundant frozen tissue
sequencing whole genomes from folk from
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
is not standard although methods are
improving
proving there as well the computational
demands for analysis and even storage of
the data generated from a whole genome
sequence are really enormous and can't
be trivialized maybe most important is
that right now only a small fraction the
genome is currently clinically
informative we can sequence the whole
genome but if clinicians or even
researchers again with nor 99 percent of
what we find it might be a better
allocation of resources to focus on the
small fraction with immediate
implications and do so over a larger
number of samples and also by sequencing
the entire genome and distributing your
sequence reads across three billion
bases a sequence coverage invest the
detection sensitivity are relatively
limited right now whole genomes are
typically not sequence to greater than
fifty or hundred fold coverage but to
detect mutations that may only be
present in a small fraction these
heterogeneous tumor samples requires
deeper sequencing approaches which are
really what I'm going to be talking
about for the rest of the time so it's
two key innovations that allow us to go
from the broad sequencing and entire
genomes to focus sequencing of the most
clinically or biologically relevant
fraction and do so a deeper coverage for
greater detection sensitivity and these
are firstly abilities to perform target
capture by hybridization also by
amplification as I'll mention in a
couple slides there are two main classes
of Durham target capture but this allows
us to enrich for the specific regions of
the genome that we are most interested
in sequencing and analyzing and the
second is molecular bar coding which
allows us to pool libraries created from
different samples into a single
sequencing run taking advantage of the
huge yields of an Illumina hi see where
sequencing a single sample anything
short of whole genome would probably be
overkill but by focusing on specific
regions of jeans and and ligating a
unique molecular barcode which in this
case is a six base nucleotide sequence
to the molecules corresponding to a
particular sample we can pool bar coded
libraries for multiple samples in
simultaneously analyze them this allows
us to study same
peoples will decrease costs higher
throughput with less DNA required for
each sample and do so at a higher depth
of coverage so as I just mentioned there
are a couple different flavors for
trying to capture one large category
encompassing methods that perform
captured by amplification which is
basically a hike to put the multiplex
PCR reaction using gene specific or loca
specific primers these are typically
better suited for smaller panels fewer
numbers of genes are often coupled with
smaller instruments like alumina hi
sleek of the eye in time for GM
hybridization capture allows you to
sequence a larger fraction of the genome
here you can design sequence-specific
probes that can hybridize genomic DNA
fragments that correspond to the genes
or regions of interest and again there
are lots of different companies that
have developed methods for performing
hybridization capture as well as
amplicon capture these can be designed
in a custom fashion by individual
investigators or labs or there are
cataloged panels that exist the
hybridization capture a lot because it
targets typically a greater fraction of
the genome is coupled with a higher
scale higher food production scale
instruments like a high CTR intron coat
on another advantage of hybridization
capture is it provides information about
copy number and rearrangements which
typically aren't as particular
translocations cannot be identified by
amplicon capture unless you know exactly
where the break point DNA's occur so the
method that that i'll be speaking about
that we've put the most work into
optimizing and developing here at
sloan-kettering we call impact so impact
dance for integrated mutation profile of
actionable cancer targets conceptually
it's really not different from
approaches that other cancer centers
have taken or other commercial entities
like foundation medicine have taken
where you can prepare sequence libraries
design custom probes for capturing the
exons of however many cancer genes
you're interested in sequencing in our
case it's two probes for all of the
exons at 340 cancer genes perform a
hybridization reaction select a
complementary sequence sequence these
libraries to very deep coverage up to a
thousand oaks cover
which can still be accomplished in the
single lane of a high C 2000 or in a
flow cell of a high of 2,500 and these
can then be aligned to the genome and
analyzed the process that we've
developed and the data that I'm going to
present all the library prep and the
captures have been done in my lab the
sequencing has been done in
collaboration with audience reality and
our genomics court sloan-kettering and
then all of the genomic analysis has
also been getting back in my lab so with
this approach the coverage is very
specific to the target exons instance
we're not wasting coverage across the
introns are energetic sequence although
I'll be the first to acknowledge that
there isn't there's information in the
incomes and non-coding sequence that you
may be missing out by sequencing just
these protein coding exons but still as
a way to maximize our limited resources
and sequence as many samples as possible
you get a lot of bang for your buck by
focusing just on these exons so here's
an example of a lung cancer tumor normal
pair and probably can't see the small
gray bars representing individual
sequence reads but you can see that
these reads pileup on the specific exons
of in this case the gene EGFR you zoom
in on the actual sequence you can find
sites where there are somatic mutations
present in the tumor but not present in
the normal here's an example of a
mutation la 58 are in egfr its present
about twenty-four percent of weeds in
the tumor but zero percent of leads a
new normal and as I mentioned there many
different classes of alterations that we
can detect I won't go into details about
copy number alterations and remains
although I guess a will show here that
these methods are suitable for FFPE
samples biopsy specimen cytology
specimens a lot of work has gone into
optimizing these techniques to study
real world cancer samples typical of
what we encounter in the molecular
diagnostics lab here at sloan-kettering
obviously one of the first experiment
that we performed along these lines that
was probably about two years ago now we
took a series of FFP in lung cancers is
259 grams of DNA from each tumor in this
case I'm showing one of the 12 lung
cancers where we were easily able to
detect the chaos mutation which has
already known
from prior Sequenom genotyping music
tumor but we also in our copy number
analysis identified a number of copy
number gains and losses shown here i
guess is sears and when you look at self
i'm sorry this is the first time I've
showrooms plots out each on the bottom
each data point represents a an exon of
one of the three hundred genes that were
sequencing and by looking at what genes
these exons belong to you can see
through increases in copy number level
underlining amplifications effectiveness
genes so there was an implication in n
cakes 2.1 which is commonly observed in
in lung adenocarcinoma I mean an even
higher level amplification in egfr and
his tumor which is not actually that
common among cancer mutations in the
more common but they may have
therapeutic implications for this
particular patient we push the limits of
DNA in put down as low as 15 nanograms
where in this case we were able to use
15 anagrams from an ultrasound-guided
FNA from a small cell lung cancer
patient for which surgical resection
specimens are very rarely available and
we've got a number of mutations and copy
number alterations some of them
targetable in including an fgfr1
amplification particular small cell lung
cancer so for the rest of time I talked
about applications largely
research-based but before moving on I
want to emphasize that these approaches
for performing targeted sequencing of
key cancer genes have important
applications in the clinical labs and
maybe one of the most important
applications is the prospective
sequencing for clinical diagnosis we can
also use the same approaches to perform
retrospective sequencing for
translational research applications of
which I alluded to at the beginning you
can discover druggable mutations and
rare tumor types that aren't part of the
Cancer Genome Atlas or Vicey GC but it
at a large Cancer Center perhaps we have
a large enough number of these rare
tumor types that you can begin to study
them in genomic level we can identify
biomarkers that predict outcomes or
response to therapy
and by sampling multiple tumors from a
single patient understand tumor
progression of existence and that's
largely what I'm going to talk about
through the rest of the time so I just
had this slide at the beginning and I
bring it up again now because there's
one more point that I didn't mention so
I eventually lung cancer there are you
can subdivide lung cancer melanoma into
different subtypes according to which
genes have driver mutations but these
discoveries were they came about by very
different means so in lung cancer we
actually didn't know anything about the
genetics of lung cancer other than the
fact that chaos is mutated about a
quarter of all lung cancer patients
around 2003-2004 when there were some
clinical trials being performed tyrosine
kinase inhibitors that overall showed
not great response for for most lung
cancer patients but a small subset of
lung cancer patients had a very profound
response so through retrospective
analysis it was determined that the
patients who responded were harboring
EGFR mutations in their tumors that egfr
mutation served as a very effective
biomarker for the efficacy of these
drugs whereas in melanoma it was through
large-scale genomic analysis to somatic
sequencing studies of melanoma that led
to the discovery of the Iraq mutations
and from that discovery came the
rational development of b-raf inhibitors
so it sort of happened in Reverse we
went in lung cancer from a clinical
observation to the underlying genetics
and melanoma the genetics was worked out
leading to the rational development of
view african tears and this is kind of
representative of our efforts to
discover biomarkers there are the two
strategies for using genomics to
identify targets of therapy the first
being one being the genotype to
phenotype approach where you can
determine the tumor genomic profile and
then prospective ly select the best drug
or combination of drugs to elicit a
clinical response this is what's being
done in the clinical labs today to try
to determine the best course of action
our best course of treatment for a
patient whose tumors been profile but we
also have patients who have been treated
and have exhibited a phenotype and we
can go backwards to determine the
underlying genotype it conferred
response to that drug or resistance to
that drug so the question here is can we
retrospectively identify the genetic
basis for drug response in patients
exhibiting clinical responses so I'm
going to provide a few examples of the
latter where we've gone back to try to
identify and discover biomarkers of drug
response or drug resistance and to try
to elucidate the underlying genetics the
first example is in bladder cancer and
this is a collaboration with the GU
service here at sloan-kettering goba ire
and David solid ending the drawing from
medical oncology pic model notting from
pathology and Sassoon you Scott from my
lab and Barry Taylor from computational
biology where we studied bladder cancer
patients who responded to enter location
now the mtor pathway is shown here in
its most general form signaling through
a Katie and pi3 kinase leads to the
inhibition of gse 1 and TSU to which are
negative regulators event or signaling
mtor itself can be inhibited by
rapamycin and other raffle logs like
everolimus and temperature alignments
and I mentioned that we were studying
the basis for response to I'm torn
admission bladder cancer em torn
admission has really not been very
effective in bladder cancer patients and
in fact out of a stage phase 2 clinical
trial of stage four bladder cancer
patients treated with everolimus there
was really only one patient in that
entire trial here at sloan-kettering who
exhibited a response but that response
was very significant we you can see from
the scans here the patient after many
other therapies presenting the stage for
bladder cancer and after 15 months
basically was cured the disease it's
been almost it's been more than two
years almost three years now and the
patient still is on drug and is still
responding to everolimus
so for this particular patient we had
the opportunity because we had frozen
tumor tissue and match blood and patient
consent to perform whole genome
sequencing to see if we could determine
which if there was a mutation that
plausibly explained why this patient was
responding so well to the mtor inhibitor
everolimus and what we found was that
there were seventeen thousand total
somatic mutations in these patients to
none of those just under 200 were within
protein-coding gene so as a first pass
these were the sensible ones who to
focus on and of those 184 one mutation
in particular Potter I this was a
frameshift in dell in TSE one so i
mentioned the GSC one is a negative
regulator of mtor signaling so if you
have a frameshift in TSE one that leads
to loss of function of T se1 increased
signaling through mtor perhaps hyper
hyper activation of the mtor pathway and
make these patients hypersensitive or
more sensitive to this particular
patient hypersensitive to employ mission
so sorry we we found this Tsun and we're
eager to to follow up or okay one
question we have from technical
standpoint was whether these results
could be replicated in the ffe tumor
obtained from this patient so then we
applied our impact method to study 230
genes too deep coverage sequence 591 X
coverage to this patient's tumor the
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
specimen obtained at the time of surgery
and what we found is that all seven
mutations found by whole genome
sequencing in these 230 genes were
easily detectable in the FFPE sample and
in fact there were three additional
mutations that were missed by whole
genome sequencing that were detected in
the FFPE sample and we went back and
looked at the whole genome data it's not
that these mutations weren't there and
in fact there was the same level of
evidence supporting these mutations the
whole genome data book because the
coverage was lower and the mutant in the
mutation frequency was relatively low
they weren't called was with the deeper
coverage we were able to
bows and it's included a frameshift
mutation APC a point mutation fgfr4 are
an important ation in s5 and shown here
the evidence was there but just the
deeper coverage of impact allowed us to
detect presentations so now this gave us
the opportunity to analyze the other
patients involved in the trial and we
had ffpe tissue available for 14 other
patients really no frozen tissue so
these these tumors without by
traditional methods would have been
really would have been unable to study
these by next-generation sequencing
approaches but with impact we could
achieve greater than 100 x sequence
coverage for 14 patients and what we
found was that GSC one was the second
most commonly mutated gene among these
patients so there were five patients
including the index responder with
mutations in tsc one and four of these
five had nonsense or Frank chip in
activating mutations so what this
initially we were discouraged by this if
we thought that tsc1 was going to be the
biomarker they predicted who is going to
respond clearly there were four other
patients with tsc1 mutations who didn't
have such a profound response but when
we looked at the waterfall plots of
these tumors we found that it was almost
exactly these patients with T a single
mutations that derived some clinical
benefit so what's plotted here on the
horizontal axis is the relative change
in the size of the tumor so tumors the
trunk have arrows to the left and the
tumors they progressed her to the right
and in blue are the tumors with tsc1
mutations and in green are the tumors
were toc one wild-type and while there
was only one sample that met the
clinical criteria for response which is
the index responder shown to the left of
their red dotted line but there were
other patients whose tumors did shrink
in response to the drug and his patients
almost to a person had mutations in TSE
one so this suggested to us that tsc1
was very informative as to which
patients might drive Chronicle benefit
as to why one patient responded so much
better than the others this is a you
know it's still an open
question and it's probably due to the
other combination of mutations the cold
curd with the TSE one mutation that we
saw in particular the patient who
responded had a nonsense mutation nf2
which is also regulate event or
signaling so perhaps increased the
dependence of mtor in this particular
tumor but members of the solid lab are
still investigating why this patient and
why this combination of mutations could
have elicited a greater response in the
second example I want to present sort of
a follow-up to that first study where we
studied m20 of inhibition and kidney
cancer and this was also with the geo
group here at sloan-kettering in
particular Martin boss james shay and
bob motor ningbo channels a pathologist
studying kidney cancer malignancy
Xandros grama a postdoc in my lab and it
was a very similar case of bladder
cancer but one big difference is that
mtor inhibitors rather than being
administered only within clinical trials
and bladder cancer are administered a
standard of care in kidney cancer Peter
everolimus contempt or alignments are
FDA approved in kidney cancer so we
actually have at sloan-kettering
hundreds of patients who received
everolimus over the last several years
and we can try to better understand why
some patients responding some go just as
part of the standard of care in the
treatment of kidney cancer so this is a
distribution pulled together by martin
bosuh male oncology showing the
variation in outcomes a variation
response actually a variation on the
duration in which these patients receive
drug is a surrogate for response for
over 300 patients with renal cell
carcinoma over the last decade or so and
the median progression-free survival of
these patients was about five months but
you can see from this graph that some
patients progressed almost immediately
and others run drug for many years
without any fortune excuse me without an
internal progression so what we did as a
small pilot was to take some of the
outliers some of the long-term
responders who are on drug for more than
20 months and some of the non-responders
who progressed almost
Lee sequenced them using our impact
assay to deep sequence coverage and ask
whether there were any genetic mutations
that correlate with response and I'll
show you our results right now so we
sequence 6 responders and 49 responders
and in the first responder that we
sequenced we've got a number of
mutations including a frameshift in Dale
and TLC 1 so this is a different site of
different amino acid than the bladder
cancer case but it leads to the same
phenotype a loss of function of tsc1
perhaps increase signaling through em
Torin increased dependence on the mtor
pathway and also our copy number
analysis suggests that chromosome 9
which harbors tsc1 exhibited single copy
loss suggesting that there's complete
functional inactivation tsc1 in his
patient so the next patient we sequence
didn't have any alteration tsc1 but
rather had a point mutation in the mtor
kinase itself so this was a mutation in
the kinase domain of mtor and was a
novel mutation but perhaps suggest and
I'll come back to this point but but may
explain why the patient responds to them
to inhibitor third patient we sequence
didn't have any point mutations in any
of the genes we looked at with the copy
number analysis suggests complete
homozygous deletion of tsc2 so again
it's a different gene but a negative
regulator of mtor so we found mutations
in three different genes all involved in
the pathway all of which plausibly
confer sensitivity to employ inhibition
the fourth patient we sequence had a
different frame shift deletion and tsc1
this was a two nucleotide deletion in
different exon but still suggesting loss
of function tsc1 and like before coupled
with a single copy loss of TLC one from
a copy in my analysis leading to
complete functional and activation into
a c1 the fifth patient didn't have any
mutation had mutations and deletions but
not in genes that we readily link to the
mtor signaling and the same was true
participation we found mutations and Dax
and keep one and deletions of chromosome
14 and 15 but nothing that we would
plausibly link immediately linked to
interest
so it's complex and it actually got even
more complex when we lifted the
non-responders so the first non
responder that we sequence had a
mutation and mtor so this is a different
mutation from the responder patient
number two but a new mutation mtor
nonetheless now this is not in a kind of
steaming mad at a concern does it do not
even admit our own domain of mtor but
suggests that the presence of a mutation
emptor is not sufficient to confer
sensitivity or allow us to predict
response to a drug and the second
patient had a mutation in tsc2 so
there's a single missense mutation it's
not like the complete homozygous
deletion of the entire gene but again
suggests that mutation in one of the
genes in the pathway isn't fun it's only
sufficient to predict response on the
third patient and the fourth patient I
remember of interesting copy number
alterations and mutations but nothing
that we would like to enter city so from
this I think there are a lot of
conclusions that learned a lot of
take-home messages that they showed us
above all it showed us that this does
work to some degree you know we didn't
know why these patients responded and we
discovered a number of genetic
explanations for response in these
patients but it's very complex and and
suggests the comprehensive mutation
profile is really necessary if we want
to characterize and discover these
biomarkers and genotype patients for
these potential alterations going
forward in the clinic so and this was
shown in the first three cases that we
sequence we found mutations in three
different genes three different
mechanisms of mutation and one it was in
in Dell and other was a point mutation
and the other was a copy number
alteration suggesting we need to be
sequencing many genes and interrogating
main potential classes of alterations
number two is that the interpretation
requires additional biological insight
as I mentioned the mtor mutation alone
wasn't sufficient to predict response
but if we look a little bit more closely
at the empty or mutation that we found
the one that occurred in the responder
is like more likely to be a driver it's
a conserved amino acid in the kinase
domain at a cluster of mutations that
have been identified through the Cancer
Genome Atlas Project and other systemic
renal cell carcinoma sequencing projects
and that's shown in diagram here the
spectrum of mutations we've been
identified and you can see our cue 22 23
k mutation isn't a cluster of mutations
potentially a hotspot that a mutational
hot spot at a conservative region in a
conserved domain whereas the mutation
the non responder is more likely to be a
passenger mutation based on
computational inference and from the
fact that it doesn't occur in a hotspot
or an inroad demain and James Shay's lab
were collaborators in this project have
performed a number of functional
follow-up experiments showing
conclusively in their experimental in
vitro system that cue 22 23 k is an
activating mutation is an activating
mutation e 9 19 b is not and that the
mutation q 22 23 k is remain sensitive
to rapamycin and rapper logs like ever
Lyman control arms number three is that
we come we couldn't predict the clinical
response in every patient so there were
two patients where we performed our
impact assay generated deep sequence
coverage but we didn't find any
plausible links to enter signaling and
there are many reasons why this could
have been a case it could be that these
that it was mutations in other genes
outside of our panel that were
responsible for sensitivity it could be
that it wasn't mutations in the DNA at
all but rather gene expression
differences or other epigenetic effects
like DNA methylation the code of silence
tsc 1 or 2 Z 2 or other other genes
involved in mtor signaling and we would
need other platforms other complementary
approaches to investigate these it could
be that we have an incomplete
understanding of the pathway and maybe
the mutations that we found are exactly
the mutation that confer response but we
just don't fully understand all of the
components to the mtor pathway
or it could be that there's two more
heterogeneity that's at play here and
that we're sampling the wrong region of
the tumor and we have some interesting
evidence that in some of these cases
clearly tumor heterogeneity is does
exist but we're finding different sub
homes that have different mutations
within the mtor pathway explaining why
these patients may have responded so I
don't have time to go into those details
but we know a lot about tumor
heterogeneity from studies from the
sanger center and elsewhere especially
in renal cell carcinoma suggesting that
analyses that we perform and others
perform a challenge for this
heterogeneity and a final quick example
is a case where we we said the patient
that had initially responded to a b-raf
inhibitor this is a melanoma patient who
is one of the first patients to receive
erap inhibitor in clinical trials but
went on to progress on that drug so by
applying approaches we could identify
mechanisms of resistance to be wrapped
in addition and this was working on the
Levi Garraway and the flag lay at
dana-farber and the Bois Institute in
Boston so and this was previously
published a couple years ago in the
journal in pathology but I use it an
example an example of other studies that
were currently conducting with patients
who are receiving targeted therapies on
off clinical trials at sloan-kettering
movin can apply these approaches to
identify the genomic basis for
resistance so this was a 38 year old
melanoma patient who had initially
responded to and then apply resistance
to the maratha then you can see without
any fancy imaging that the patient who
initially presented with a lot of
subcutaneous metastatic posits upon
receiving the drug for several weeks at
a remarkable rebound and then a few
weeks later unfortunately is the case
for many patients who receive these
targeted therapies most patients who
receive his target therapies ultimately
progressed and then did pass away of his
disease
so we had the opportunity to
retrospectively analyzed DNA from the
resistant tumor from the pretreatment
from a pretreatment tumor and from match
normal tissue from this patient and try
to identify the genetic basis for
resistance and what we did was secretly
using a earlier version of this acid
sequence 138 genes and when we compared
the post relapse to minus tumor
progression to match normal we found 14
somatic mutations in these onions and
those are shown here we went back to the
pretreatment rumor and look to see which
of those were present we found the 12 of
those 14 were present and easily
detectable prior to treatment but two
showed no evidence in the pretreatment
sample and these were mutations in
mequon and rhett and it could be that
they will present very low levels and
just grew out when exposed to the
selection pressures of the drug there
could be that these were novel mutations
that accrued during the time of the
patient was on treatment you don't
really know I think very likely these
contentions were present and then
throughout in response selective
pressures but nevertheless we can look
at these two mutations of these two
genes and see if either one is a good
candidate for a resistance mechanism and
in fact mek1 is the perfect candidate
for the mutation meth one's a perfect
candidate for release mechanism because
mech is the kinase immediately
downstream or be rap in the map kinase
signaling pathway so you can imagine you
have a mutation in veera activate the
pathway and then through inhibition of
beer app you can run silence a pathway
but reactivate it through a mutation and
neck downstream of the view app which
has been inhibited and in fact this is
what was shown in follow-up experiments
in Levi's lab performed by his post on
Kerry Emery that this mech mutation when
engineering tanvir a few melanoma cells
did lead to increased growth both in the
presence of the BF inhibitor and the mek
inhibitor from astrazeneca suggesting
that had this patient received the
mechanist particular MEK inhibitor he
would have been resistant
right as well so finally I want to
mention again what I had mentioned at
the beginning is that this is an
opportunity to perform retrospective
analysis for biomarker discovery but
really to change the way patients are
diagnosed and treated and DNA sequencing
as I hope you're convinced can augment
traditional histology based diagnosis
smacking and replace radiology is not
going to replace traditional histology
pathology but providing extra molecular
level of information it's especially
important given the expanding number of
targeted therapies that are effective
only in particular biological context
for patients with Harbor mutations in
particular genes and pathways that are
targeted by those drugs we like other
cancer centers were in the process of
building the capability to perform
routine molecular analysis using
next-generation sequencing on patients
as part of their standard diagnosis and
treatment and and I thought it would be
useful to spend just the last few
minutes discussing some of the
challenges and considerations in setting
up these clinical sequencing pipelines
there are many technical challenges some
of which I mentions in which I haven't
any lab is confronted with a choice of
how to select which platforms to use in
which genes to sequence provided that
the desire is to suit once a small or
target panel rather than the entire
genome do the group loading and resource
concerns the asset performance must be
validated and demonstrated to achieve
maximum sensitivity and specificity and
reproducibility especially if it's
something we can be run be a certified
clinical lab and needs to be compatible
with all types of clinical samples small
biopsies in particular as well as
cytology samples like for fusions and
even urine and other fluids and FNA is
which are often the only samples
available for clinical diagnosis and we
don't have the luxury of restricting the
analysis to the largest highest purity
frozen specimens that are typically
reserved before the research projects
like those perform at attention to your
novels
and the workflows must be optimized in
order to achieve the shortest possible
turnaround time say that these results
can be received in a reasonable time
frame and used in the decision making
for treatment decision making process
for these patients on computational
challenges I've barely talked about that
these are enormous both in the
development of algorithms to detect all
classes of alterations and and
developing algorithms that can do so
with highest sensitivity for detecting
alterations in law purity tumors
separate approaches may be necessary to
look the point mutations in bella's copy
number alterations on translocations and
I think there's no universal consensus
as to what the best algorithms are and I
think the best algorithms will remain to
be developed on the infrastructure for a
lab that's going to be performing the
data analysis and storing novice data
and integrating molecular data with
clinical systems and clinical
information tied to the hospital needs
to be built and the requirements are
very strong are very high and the
training and recruitment of
computational biologist with those
expertise is proving to be a challenge
for for many centers the interpretation
itself is never straightforward one as
one broadens the amount of territory
sequence one encounters mutations of
unclear significance these could be
novel mutations in Nome cancer genes
they could be known mutations and their
own cancer genes in new tumor types and
none of these are straightforward to
interpret i mentioned tumor
heterogeneity we need to if we find a
mutation president a low frequency who
can infer there might be sub phoneable
we don't necessarily know what the
clinical implications of that are if the
patient's tumor only has ten percent of
the tumor cells that contain a
particular mutation will chargen that
mutation be effective maybe it would be
maybe you wouldn't be an idea that's
been pioneered by a number of cancer
centers including on University of
Michigan Farber Cancer Center is the
idea of a genomic tumor tumor board
which involves a panel of experts
with diverse a clinical and genomic and
computational activities to convene and
together interpret the clinical
significance of these mutations but this
is not something that can be scaled up
readily as more and more patients are
being subject to this analysis molecular
reports need to be developed that are as
informative as possible for the
furnishings that are ordering the tests
and receiving the results potentially
contain an interpretive comments
suggesting what the clinical
significance of mutations are and what
rentable relevant clinical trials may
exist for these patients all this needs
to be done in a regular in the
regulatory compliant way involving
regulations issued by federal and state
wide bodies for clinical labs and
clinical tests some of these mutations
if it's an unbalanced a you need to be
independently confirmed and right now
the platforms that exist to
independently confirm these mutations
may be lower sensitivity than the
initial sequencing platform use to
discover them themselves so we may be
limited by the sensitivity in those
asses the reimbursement and recovery of
these costs of recovery costs of these
tests is still a little bit murky and
even as the reimbursement rates improve
for the test themselves the very large
R&D efforts that are required to develop
these tests are really using firms that
cannot be recovered and there are many
ethical and legal and social
considerations that exist including
whether or not use patients need to
provide informed consent for routine
diagnostic tests I think everybody
agrees that the research is performed
using patient consent but the idea that
a patient may need to consent to have a
routine diagnostic test performed
because it includes sequencing DNA from
the Germans brand-new and is something
that we've decided here needs to be done
in the course of the sequencing a major
concern is that will encounter
incidental findings that may not even be
related to the cancers the patient's
cancer that may have implications for
other diseases and implications for the
patient's themselves and their family
members
and these need to be returned in a way
that preserves patient autonomy but
still isn't the best interests of the
patient from a clinical standpoint there
are intellectual property claims that
exist and as I'm sure you're all aware
at least in the United States the IP law
surrounding biomarkers and mutations and
genes that have clinical significance is
very in flux right now and outreach and
education physicians and patients is
going to be necessary so that all of
these new mutations all these genes can
be maximum utilized by people that may
not have a complete molecular
understanding of complete understanding
the molecular biology genetics so that's
all I wanted to talk about I know I'm up
against the limits at the time but I
want to take the time to acknowledge the
numbers of my lab shown here as well as
the molecular members have been
molecular diagnostic service in our
technology department on our genomic
score and bioinformatics for and other
collaborators whose work I mentioned
here I think there's time for a few
questions so I think at this point I'll
go over to the QA and see if I can
answer the questions that you lost ok so
I'm sorry ok can we follow genetic
mosaicism and tumors on genetic
evolution of the primary tumor and also
potential discordance with metastasis
synchronic and meet a clinic a metaphor
yeah synchronous meet a seasoned vet
from the top management prostitute
absolutely so we're doing this in a
number of projects you know it relies on
having multiple samples obtained from
the same patient so autopsy patients are
a good source for tissue where we can
look at normal evolution we're now
looked at patients where we've obtained
up to 20 different metastasis patients
who develop resistance of particular
therapies and what we've seen is that
the extremely is evolved through the
for a revolution to evolve independent
mechanisms for drug resistance so not
growing these details I mentioned a case
where a beer after melanoma patient and
developed resistance of geography mek
inhibition you saw that there were
different metastases in that patient
just from the photographs and
unfortunately we only had available
tissue available for one of those
metastases for our analysis it was very
possible that field sequence different
metastases were found we would have
found different mechanisms of existence
so that's one example of studying
genetic evolution we can also send for
the same region multiple times to see
differences in the genetic composition
of the tumor and report provides to the
question about metastasis we have a
large project now where we're studying
trios of samples obtained from colon
cancer patients where we have the
primary colon cancer liver metastases
and not normal tissue and are looking
for biomarkers and metastasis food
mutations that may be present in the
river met foot on pheasant and primary
colon cancer often we're what we're
finding actually is that the metastasis
and the primary or fight concordant and
most much of the discordant can be
explained by heterogeneity during the
primary so that if you find something
that's not in the primary tumor but we
found it in the metastasis we can go
back and find you in the primary key
sample different regions of the primary
but we're just now beginning to look at
the differences between synchronous and
the task mama tachyonic I'm excited
synchronous and the tackiness metastasis
in these patients and I think it's a
great question and it's something that
he's nothing's gonna last an extra so it
just looks like there there are a few
seconds left one last question how can
you differentiate driver from passenger
mutations easily I think there's no easy
way there are a few different approaches
there's a statistical argument you can
make that really just comes from
profiling lots of tumors from laxer like
that again this is the first taken by
the Cancer Genome Atlas and other
projects where you can say because this
mutation occurs
worst it more significantly than you
expect a random chance that this must be
a driver mutation but the but were
through computational modeling looking
at evolutionary conservation and spend
protein structure you might be able to
confer functional significance for not
only real way to conclusively prove that
a mutation is a driver rather than a
passengers to functional experiments and
it's almost impossible to completely
replicate replicate the biological
context food in the tumor ending in
vitro or even the exact system so it
could be that a mutation is not showing
any functional consequence in cell lines
but if it occurred in the same
combination of mutations with a divot in
the tumor it's functional significance
may be unmasked that sense so I don't
know how coherent that answer was but
there's really no great way but I think
the best you know the most practical way
is to profile lots of tumors and look
for statistical enrichment over what
you'd expect by chance I'm the best
widest best way to sequence lots of
tumors is to apply more targeted
approaches rather than town although
having said that the data coming out
from icgc in TCGA will hopefully reveal
a number of driver alterations that can
then be confirmed to function follow so
I think that's it I want to mention that
the website shown here can be used to
obtain continuing education credits as
for all of the file from penstock EE and
I'll thank you for your attention for
attending the conference and hopefully
we'll have a chance to interact more
personally very soon well thank you very
much
you